(somber music)
- [Jacqueline] When I lived in Queens,
I went to the beauty
parlor every two weeks;
I still do it here in this
independent living community.
It's the same routine.
This routine is my life;
I have been used to it ever
since I came to America.
Look, I'm 91 years old, and I
can't stop the aging process
but I try to remedy whatever I can.
- [Thelma] If you want to
call it a beauty routine,
see, I don't; I call it just
taking care of yourself.
I do it as part of my living.
I don't think I feel beautiful,
I feel like I'm Thelma.
(dramatic orchestral music)
(soft piano music)
- [René] Change is hard.
Change is hard at any age.
But being a senior and leaving your home
and leaving familiar
faces and starting new;
routine's important.
So if they're in the habit
of getting their hair done
on a Friday at one o'clock,
they still want Friday at one o'clock.
I'm René Carpenito. I'm
the salon coordinator
and hair stylist at Riverwalk salon.
I've been here for fourteen years,
and working in a residence like this,
it does give you
enjoyment, being with them,
it makes them feel good
because that's what they're
supposed to be doing.
They've been through it all.
Doing their hair and making them pretty
and making them feel good,
you also help them get through
their day a little easier.
(somber violin music)
- [Jacqueline] I was born in 1927.
I was a teenager during
the holocaust in France.
There were days when
you couldn't take a bath
because there was nothing,
but during the war I had one lipstick,
and I remember it was called Rouge Baiser,
which means red kiss.
Lipstick made me feel beautiful,
so it's important to me
to keep myself clean and to keep myself
looking the best I can.
We came to this country
after the war in 1947.
I met my husband.
I was married 65 years.
After my husband died I felt very lonely,
and I was in terrible
shape when I came here;
but the beauty salon is
downstairs on the lower floor.
Morning.
I go to the beauty parlor every two weeks.
It's an intimate place.
I talk to people.
You feel very good going there;
I know that I'll come
out and I'll look decent.
(gentle piano music)
- [Thelma] Two years ago
my husband fell, and died.
I never thought that
this would happen to me.
At the beginning I froze;
and I said, "Who am I?"
Always dressed, see?
This is the way my family
was; we always dressed.
This is my life today,
it cannot be what it was.
I have to maintain who I am.
I love clothes.
My hair is the same as
it was when I was twenty,
It's very simple and I
don't want to lose myself;
so far, I have not.
- [René] Thelma's been here
a little while.
Good morning.
- [René] She's very sharp;
she's very into fashion.
Thelma has her style;
she knows what she likes.
- [Thelma] And not too short down here.
- [René] And I do what she
likes, week after week.
She shares a lot of stories
and she goes out often,
and she's just living
life and enjoying life.
(gentle piano music)
I feel like coming here
gives me the opportunity
to have 95 grandmothers.
It's a very comfortable place to be.
They're getting older,
and their life is getting a little harder,
so when you're the one that
makes their day better,
that gives you so much more fulfillment.
(gentle piano music)